字幕: Ryan Hamlett
校正: 穎君 紀
皆さん、宇宙と聞くと
ワクワクドキドキしませんか？
しますよね。
そんな宇宙について
私は研究をしています。
宇宙を研究するといっても
その方法、対処、
それからどういって行うかと
今実にさまざまです。
で、私は理論的に
宇宙に漂う惑星について、
主に物理学の観点で研究をしています。
で、こういったことを普段から知っているという方は、
皆さんの中にはほとんどおられないと思いますし、
またそういった方が身近におられるという方も
また少ないのではないでしょうか。
つまり皆さんと私の間には
普段大きな間があるという訳です。
で、この間が故に私達、特に理論研究者は
多くの場合、誤解を受けます。
皆さんから見ると大抵こういう風に見られる訳ですね。
人づきあいをほとんどしないで
部屋にこもって難しい式を
解いてばかりというものです。
これはですね、私の自宅にあった
使い終わったカレンダーですけれども、
このカレンダー裏側にはですね
たくさん式が書いてあります。
（観客の笑い声）
皆さんの御想像の通りですね
ふとした拍子に所構わず突然計算をし出す。
まあそんな人間です。
（観客の笑い声）
確かにそういう側面もある訳ですけれども
私達はあくまで職業として
研究を行っている訳ですので
人とのつながり、とても大切です。
で、特にですね、間のある人との交流
というのはとても大切です。
今日はですね、私の最近の研究を題材に
間の大切さというのを皆さんと一緒に
考えてみたいと思います。
私が宇宙を研究していますと言うと
初対面の方から受ける多くの質問は
「地球以外に生命はいますか？」
と言うものです。
この中の皆さんにも、知りたいという
人は多いのではないでしょうか。
実は研究者もこれを知りたい
と思っている人はたくさんいます。
私もそれにつながる研究をしています。
私たちは地球外生命体というのは
全くもって知らないわけですから
それが地球の生命と何が同じで違うのか
それも当然知らないわけですけれども
地球の生命が必ず必要とするものは何かということを
考えることから始めるわけです。
そう思ったときに、一つ
重要なものは液体の水です。
私たちは水なくしては
生きてはいけませんし
また地球の生命どこで生まれたか
これはわかっていませんけれども
有力な仮説は海の中、海底ですね、
そこで生まれたのではないか
ということが考えられています。
つまり、地球上の生命と液体の水というのは
切っても切り離せないと言うわけです。
それを踏まえて、私は
この広い宇宙空間のどこにどれだけ生命を
育み得る海というものがあるのだろうか
これを物理学の観点で明らかにしたい
というふうに考えているわけです。
こちらは皆さん、ご存知の
私たちの住む太陽系の模式図です。
煌々と光り輝く太陽の周りを
8 つの惑星が回っています。
この図の中で海を持つ天体と言うのは
ただ一つ、地球だけです。
しかし、それはこの太陽系に今、海は
一つしかないということではありません。
この広大な宇宙空間の中の、
本当にちっぽけな領域でしかない
太陽系の中にでさえ、今まさにこの瞬間
複数の海が存在している。
そんなことが近年の惑星
探査でわかってきました。
そういった地球海の海はどこにあるのかというと
例えば木星の衛星であるエウロパ
土星の衛星であるエンセラダス
そして海王星よりもさらに太陽から離れた
ところを回っている冥王星です。
こういった天体は太陽から
非常に遠いところにありますので
表面の温度は摂氏- 150 度 、 -200 度
という想像を絶する極寒の世界です。
ですので、ご覧のとおり
表面は完全に凍りついています。
しかし、天体は中に行けば行くほど
温度が高くなるのでその氷が溶けている。
つまり、内部海があるのだということが
わかってきたわけです。
この探査が明らかにした
内部海の存在ですけれども、
実は理論的には不思議な存在です。
で、なぜかというと、水と岩石の塊を
-150 度、 -200 度の極寒の所に
何十億年も置いておいたら、
それはとうの昔に凍りついてしまっている
はずだという風に考えられるからです。
しかし現実にはそうなっていないと言うわけです。
なぜそうなっていないのかと
結論から言ってしまいますけれども、
エウロパやエンセラダスについては
これらが衛星であると言うことがポイントです。
少々ですね、イメージしづらいと思いますが
これらの衛星はそれ自体がですね
変形してしまうほど
強力な潮汐力を受けながら
木星や土星の周りを回っています。
この周期的に変形が起こることによって、
摩擦熱が発生する。
これを潮汐加熱と呼びますけれども、
それによってですね。
内部海が凍らないんだ
ということがわかっています。
問題は冥王星です。
冥王星は衛星ではないので
この潮汐による加熱はありません。
そのため、なぜこの海が凍らないのか
というのは大きな謎だったわけです。
そしてこの謎を解明しない限り
宇宙のどこにどれだけ海かあるのかというのは
当然わからないと言うわけです。
実はこの謎、我々が解いたんですけれども
今日はですね、その人間ドラマをご紹介したいと思います。
冥王星と言うのは実に興味深い天体で
その内部海が凍っていないというだけではなくて、
その上にある氷もまた私たちが
知っている氷よりもはるかに硬い、
ということが先行研究でわかっていました。
こういった冥王星の物理的に
不思議な性質というものについて、
私は私と同じような手法や分野の
研究者と一緒に研究していました。
我々は当初どういうふうに考えたかというと
きっとこれはですね。
海や氷に大量の不純物が混じっていて、
それゆえに普通の水や氷と違う性質なんだ、
という風に考えたわけです。
このアイデアをもとに
どれだけの不純物が必要かというのを計算して
私はその結果を同僚の
倉本さんに持っていきました。
蔵元さんは宇宙化学を専門とされる方で、
惑星を構成する物質に大変詳しい方です。
で、我々の研究結果を見た倉本さんは
まあ、原理的にはそういう解は
あるかもしれないけれども
現実的な解ではないねという
ようなことをおっしゃいました。
つまりですね、人工的にそういうものを作れば
何 10 億年も海は凍らないんだけども
自然にできるとは到底
思えないと言うわけです。
そりゃそうです、こんな簡単にですね、
謎が解けたらそれは謎という
ほどのものでもないわけです。
で次に、あの謎解きのきっかけ
となる出会いに移りたいと思います。
私は 2017 年度からですね、
5年間に渡る研究プロジェクトである
「水惑星学の創生」というものに参加しています。
これは、海を持つ天体の起源と進化、
これをキーワードに、
さまざまな手法、さまざまな分野の
研究者、約 70 名近くですけども、
そういうですね、いろんな人たちが
集まった大研究プロジェクトです。
このプロジェクトに参加したことで
私は実験系の人と知り合うことができました。
こちらの写真は神戸大学の谷さんですけれども
谷さんはこの横に写る装置で
冥王星の内部海ではなくてですね
土星の衛星エンセラダスの内部海を
研究しようとしていました。
何もですね、谷さん単にここに水を入れて
こう出そうとしていた訳ではありません。
そこにエンセラダスで実際に観測されている
気体を同時に流し込んで、
ガスハイドレートと呼ばれる物質を
作ろうとしていたわけです。
内部海、その名の通り天体の内部にあるので
直接見ることはできないわけですけども
この装置で再現してしまえば
どのようにガスハイドレートができるのか
自分の目で直接観察できる
というわけです。
このガスハイドレートというのは、
家庭の冷凍庫で作ることは
できませんけれども
自然界、地球上ですけれども
ごくごくありふれた物質で
大量に地球の近海でも見つかっています。
特にですね、メタンを閉じ込めたものは
メタンハイドレートと呼ばれていて、
日本のですね、将来の有望な
エネルギー源になるのではないか
ということで、注目も浴びている物質です。
谷さんという方はまさにこの
ガスハイドレートの専門家で、
この水惑星で氷衛星のガスハイドレートについての
研究を始めようとしていたわけです。
で、このガスハイドレートの話を聞いたとき
私の中でビビッと何かが来たわけでは全くありません。
当然ですね、谷さんの話を聞いたときは私の中は
エンセラダス一色になってるわけです。
で、自分の家に帰ってですね、
どれだけ時間が経ったか覚えていませんけれども
ふとした時にですね、自分の研究に
メタンハイドレートを
入れていなかったなと、
入れてみようと思ったわけです。
そこで同じく水惑星で知り合った
野口さんという方に連絡をとって
メタンハイドレートを含むさまざまな氷の
詳細な物性について教えていただいて
それを自分の計算に入れてみたわけです。
そうするとびっくりするわけです。
海が全く凍らないだけではなくて
その上にある氷も硬くなってしまったわけです。
なぜそうなったかこの後説明しますけれども
重要なことはですね
原理的にあり得る解が見つかったと言うわけです
で次にですね、これが現実的な解かということで
私は新たにですね、再びこの研究結果を
倉本さんに持っていったわけです。
そうすると冥王星の海に対しては
メタンは十分供給できるというわけです。
つまりこれは現実的な解だと言うわけです。
話はこれでまだ終わりません。
私はさらにですね、この研究結果を
関根さんという方に持っていきました。
関根さんとは以前の知り合いで
私が大学院生の頃所属していた
研究室の助教であった方で、
つまり学生と教員の立場でありました。
今はですね、関根さんはこの水惑星学の
代表を務めておられます。
我々の研究結果を聞いた関根さんは
その冥王星の内部海に
具体的にどういう種類のガスが
どれだけ供給できるのかというのを、
ご自身の実験の観点で議論して
くださったことに加えてですね、
重要なことは第 3 の冥王星の謎。
冥王星の大気組成が非常に
不思議なんですけれども
その謎もこのアイデアで解けてしまう
ということに気づかれたわけです。
私は根っからの物理屋なので
大気の組成が不思議だという、それさえ
気づいていなかったわけですけれども、
関根さんのアイデアで 3 つの謎が
同時に解けるということになったわけです。
そして私たちの研究結果がまとまったわけです。
これはそのときの記者発表をしたときの
資料になりますけれども
冥王星の内部界がなぜ凍らないのか
ということを解明しましたと。
キーワードはメタンハイドレートです。
これだけではなくて
なぜ凍らないかに加えて、
氷近くがなぜ硬いのかと
大気がなぜ不思議の組成をしているのか、
この 3 つを同時に解くことが
できましたと言うわけです。
絵にしてみるとこんな感じです。
これまで内部海と上にある氷と言うのは
直接接しているという風に
想像していたわけです。
そういうふうなことを
仮定しているがゆえに
とても不思議な性質を
持っていたわけです。
でも実際はそうではなく、
そこに間があると
ここに間があると、何もかも
自然に説明できると言うわけです。
このメタンハイドレートというのは
通常の氷よりも
断熱性が高いので、つまり天然の
断熱材になるわけです。
ですから、毛布に覆われた内部海というのは
全然冷えず固まらないわけですけれども、
その上に置かれたものと言うのは
内側から熱が全然
来ないので、すぐに冷えて
がちがちに、つまり硬く
なっていると言うわけです。
また、大気の組成は
どういうことかというと
結局大気のもとはこの海底からぼこぼこ
湧き上がってくるガスなわけですけれども、
そのガスがそのまま地上に出ていると
これまで考えていたわけですけれども、
そうではなくて、特定のガスはハイドレート
を作るのに消費されてしまっているので、
それ以外のものばっかりが地表に出てきている。
だからこそ不思議な大気組成になっていたんだと。
こういうことも全て謎が解けたというわけです。
我々の研究結果ですけども、
これは何も冥王星の理解が深まったから
重要だとそれだけではないんです。
これまで宇宙における海というのは
地球のように中心星から適切な距離にある
天体か、あるいは衛星である、
これが必要だという風に思われていたわけです。
しかし我々の考えからすれば、
思っていた以上に
海というのは長期間、何十億年も
維持することが可能である、
このように宇宙観のですね、がらっと変える
大きな発見だったと言えるわけです。
ここでもう一度振り返りたいのは
この研究結果に至った
人間ドラマですけれども、
普段間がある人との交流、
これがきっかけとなったわけです。
こう言うとですね、異分野交流が大切なんでしょうと
どこでも聞いた話になってしまうわけですけれども、
重要なのはですね、やはり普段
間がある、これも重要なことなんです。
どういうことかというと、
普段間があるからこそですね、
それぞれの専門性を伸ばして、
その上で交流することで初めて
大きな研究成果につながる、
というふうに私は信じています。
で、今日はですね、私は新たに
また普段、間のある人達と出会いました。
それは皆さんです。
皆さんとの間には間があるが故にですね
誤解を受けるということは言いましたけれども、
やはり同じで、この間も重要だ
という風に考えています。
つまり私達が専門性の高い研究ができるのは
やはりこの間があるからだ
という風に信じています。
皆さんもですね、もし今日の話を聞いて
ワクワクドキドキした方がおられれば、
間があったからですね、
それを超えて話を聞いたから
そういう気持ちになれたはずだ
という風に信じています。
で、もちろんですね、
今日私の話を聞いて、
全く何も感じないと言う方も
おられると思います、残念ながら。
そういう方はですね、きっと、
私と何も間がないか、あるいは
間が大きすぎてですね、
真に交流できていない
だけなんだと思います。
で、しかしながらそれを超えてですね、
交流できた時に
きっと、そういう方が得られるものは
誰よりも大きいという風に思います。
そのようにですね、私は間の存在、
それ自体はとても大切だという風に考えています。
御清聴どうもありがとうございました。
（拍手）